hi so this is a quick demo of civil's AI
in terms of tendering and bidding on
construction projects so after you log
into civils AI app. civils aai um you'll
have here on the left these two tabs
like projects and libraries so projects
are like construction projects you're
working on or bids for example and then
libraries are groups of documents which
you can use across different
construction projects so they could be
building codes some type of um some type
of like regulatory document or standards
so in this sense if I've uploaded a
group together some documents in a
library we have this search feature
where you can say height of fire alarm
call points for example and then you
know you can depending on which
documents you upload you can search
across all different um requirements
that you might have and then our system
like searches through these documents
and tells you the AR based on the
context of the document and the content
of it and then it highlights the section
that's been used so we have this search
feature and you can upload and create
your own libraries with your own
documents in here but what I'm going to
show you is the on the project level how
you can use civil's AI for like bidding
and tendering so if I click here example
pipeline project this will take me to a
water project where I've already
uploaded a bunch of the tender
specifications and contracts and uh
documents like drawings and reports
relating to that tender and I'm going to
show you how we built on top of this
like automated workflows on top of this
search feature I was just showing you so
again you have this Search tool where
you can type in for example projects
scope like summarize project
scope and again this is going to like
search for all these documents that I've
already uploaded and it's going to
generate me a answer so it's explaining
about this water project telling me
about it involves pipe jacking the
different sizes of the pipes that are
involved on this project um and then it
also takes me to out of all these tender
documents the section which is on scope
of works so I can read this for myself
it's important to remember that um
basically this isn't like conversational
so if I search again for something I
can't say um I can't link what I've
already written like to my previous
message so it's not like a
conversational Chat bar each one of the
searches you type in here is um unique
and not linked to anything else so you
can't have a conversation with
this um yeah and the next thing is I'm
going to show you how you can actually
run workflows on this so after you've
uploaded documents into these different
categories like specs contracts um you
basically upload them with this tool
here you can drag and drop your
documents in here and it'll take about 5
minutes or 10 minutes to process each
one of the documents depending on the
size some could be like a few seconds if
it's not many pages but larger documents
could take about five minutes to process
um I can then uh I can then show you
these workflows so if I click this
workflows tab on the left um you'll have
at the top here different categories so
you have like bidding site
investigations so for bidding for
example we have some templates already
made here so you can generate project
risk assessments you can generate legal
contra risk assessments as well and then
you have some tools for site
investigations as well which can extract
data from different types of reports
like GE technical reports lab testing
reports um and then I'm what I'm going
to show you here is for contract risk
assessments so the concept here is you
have a template for uh reviewing a
contract on on the on your project and
all of this can be customized as well
but what I'm going to do here is I'm
going to select Which documents I want
to use as an UT
so this is going to be like the
knowledge base that uh all of the
workflow is going to run off of so in
this case I want to select contracts at
the top here and I want to select my two
contracts that I want to use and then I
click confirm down here so you'll see
these loaded in on the left um and then
basically What's Happening Here is I'm
running a bunch of different searches so
this is like searching for anything
relating to change events this one's
searching for anything relating to
delays liquidated damages cost
adjustments payment terms I can also
have my own special searches down here
so if I want to customize this I can
actually type in here my own Search
terms so I could search for something
else in here if I need to um yeah and
then I can link this back into these
other two tasks I want doing on this
information I've searched from so you'll
see here now I've connected it in um I'm
not going to actually add anything there
right now but what I'm going to do is
I'm going to show you here these two
tasks which I'm doing so for each one of
the chain mentions of change events I'm
basically asking the system to draft a
summary of this in plain English for
project manager so legal documents are
normally like quite hard for you know
construction project managers to
understand so this is going to help to
summarize it in plain English what it
really means and then I'm also doing a
prompt saying does this do these
Provisions follow the best practices
score out of 10 like how standard is
this contract is there anything in there
which is
unusual and then uh create an output so
I can actually name this um contract
review for example and then it's also
going to generate some files that I can
download if I want to like an Excel or a
word file um and then once this is all
set up I can actually click this run
button up here um and then this will
start to process so I'm not going to do
that in this demo um but you can just
click this I'm just going to skip to the
part where I've already generated
so what I'm going to do here is I once
this is processed so it took about 14
seconds to process this one I'm going to
click this view outputs button so once I
click this and taken through you'll see
it skips from Editor to
outputs and I can see here on the left
all these headings which I put in so
like change events delays liquidated
damages and these different task that I
I asked it to run um on this on these
headings and I see here um like the
outputs so here it's a score 9 out of 10
in terms of change events how they're
being managed in the contract and then
it also gives you some rationale so it
explains how it's reached this decision
like what is it that was like standard
about this contract and it also says
here areas for improvement so where it's
like fallen short why it isn't 10 out of
10 and then you see here um basically
the the the references that have been
used in order to create summary so you
can click here to jump to the sections
which are relating to change events in
the contract and you can explore
basically how those are like how those
are being managed from The Source
itself then below this you have the
draft a simple summary of the of the
terms relating to that so it's easy for
you to understand and then you can just
go through each one of these on the left
and basically uh see how it how it's
scoring um and yeah anything else that
you may have chosen like output from
this but the thing here is that actually
um in the editor view you can the order
in which the preview is generated is
whether or not this is on top of this
one so if I put this below rather than
on top it's going to generate this first
rather than this one this is like the
order this is how you order what you
want in the in the report the um way in
which you order these and so I can skip
back to my results here and I can
actually download these from here is
Excel or a Word
document uh table data it works very
well in Excel but this is kind of text
output so probably better if you wanted
to put it into
word uh finally I can also show you you
can create your own custom workflows so
this is like a starter template here so
um from this point I can actually create
my own my own workflows in here and tie
all these together and connect it back
in so it's it's up to you what you want
to search in here you could type in like
project scope for example I could put
down uh R NE summarize summarize any
Earth Works
required I can also then put in here
under project scope something like
summarize any landscape summarize any
Landscaping
requirements um and then tie these all
back in so this is the way kind of works
or I could even say you know are there
any are are there any Forks required I
could ask it in different ways and then
basically hit run as long as I've got my
in this case probably specifications I'd
want the tender specifications to be
selected for this one uh and then I can
basically save this as well so if you
want to save your own copy you can click
this new copy button up here and I can
then save this as my own workflow um
which I can reuse again and again
so that's about it and if you are on the
trial and you wanted to share or you're
using this and you want to share it with
other people in your team you can
basically click this share button up
here and then I can control who I'm
sharing this with person can upload
documents into this project and then
other people in your team um only those
who are in your admin has put into your
own team um can you can share it with
them so that's a very quick summary of
um all the features on Cil AI
and how you can get started running
workflows on tender tenders and bids